we make movies in the pursuit of a
deeper truth about life and love truth
is hard to reveal but when it happens on
that big movie screen audiences no
matter where they're from feel their
heart soar with excitement
cinematographers reveal truth by using
the power of light whether it's
capturing the magic hour of sunset or
recreated in world unknown they bring to
life moving images there are sometimes
exciting sometimes heartbreaking but
always beautiful here are the nominees
for achievement in cinematography a
rival rapper Yung la-la-land lineThe
hundred William Greg Fraser moonlight
James Langston silence go Rico people
and the Oscar goes to
Lena's Sangren
[Applause]
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Lena Sandra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow Wow thank you so much the Academy
this is such an amazing honor this film
was made with so much love and passion
and struggles and it was all thanks to
you Damien Europe poetic genius and I'm
so happy I met you and I really love you
man
that Emma Ryan I think you're incredible
thanks for all the collaboration
Lionsgate producers and the entire crew
I'm really proud especially of Ari
George Tony Brad
Bogdan this camera crew and light crude
with crew that you know made its work so
and then Cecilia and Betty and Lucy else
created named it up to my mom thank you
and to my father I know you're watching
over us thank you so much
[Applause]